The Fourier
Coefficients applet lets
us explore the approximation
of periodic functions
by Fourier series.
This is the opening
screen of the applet.
On the right, you see a
series of sliders controlling
coefficients.
And they're the coefficients
of the sine terms in a Fourier
series, as you can see by
clicking this formula box.
So at this point, what we're
studying is an odd function,
a sine series, and the sliders
let us control the coefficients
of sine of k*t.
If I click the cosine
box, I'd see coefficients
of the cosine functions.
Let's go back to sine
and start to play
with the tool a little bit.
What will happen if I
move the b_2 slider?
I should get multiples
of the sine of 2t
showing up on my
graphing window.
If I push b_2 to the right,
I get positive multiples
of the sine of 2t.
The sine of 2t goes
through two full periods
when t ranges from 0 to 2pi.
And if b_2 is negative,
I get negative multiples
of the sine of 2t.
What happens if I
change b_1 in this tool?
This will add a multiple of
the sine of t to the function
that I already have.
If I push this to
the right, I'm going
to get positive multiples
of the sine of 2t,
and you can see the
alteration in the yellow graph
when I do that.
When I push b_1 to the left,
I'm adding negative multiples
of the sine of t.
You get quite a variety
of interesting functions
by playing with these
various sliders.
But it's even more
fun to try to match
a target periodic function by
means of sine or cosine series.
And the tool has built
into it a whole family
of target functions to try for.
Right now, the
target function is 0.
But we can select target A
instead, and what we have now
is a square wave.
Actually, this isn't
the standard square wave
that we deal with in
the course, quite.
It is periodic, of period
2pi, and alternates
between positive
and negative values,
but those values are pi
over 4 and minus pi over 4,
instead of plus 1 and
minus 1, as they are
for the standard square wave.
That's chosen so that the
Fourier coefficients come
out more neatly, as we'll see.
So let's try to
approximate this function
by a finite trigonometric sum.
I'm going to push the
Reset key here to reset all
the coefficients to zero,
and start trying to match
the function that I have at hand
with multiples of sine of k*t.
Let's begin with the sine
function itself, sine of t.
Well, I don't know what to do.
Let's just set it so
the maxima coincide.
Why not?
Maybe that will be
an appropriate amount
of the sine of t function
to put into the pot
when I'm trying to mix
up the square wave.
Let's go on to b_2 now.
I'm going to push the
b_2 slider to the right.
When I do that, you
see a hump forming
on the left-hand side
of the positive part
of the square wave.
If push b_2 to the left,
the same kind of hump
forms on the right-hand
side of that positive part
of the square wave.
Neither one of them seems to
be doing us very much good.
And in fact, it's creating an
asymmetry in the Fourier series
that's not present in
our target function.
It's not respecting
the symmetry that you
see around pi over 2 in
the square wave itself.
So I suspect that b_2 is not
going to be useful to us,
that the sine of 2t
is not going to be
a constituent in the Fourier
series for square wave.
In fact, I think that
none of the even sines
will be of any use to us.
And I can get rid of them and
look only at the odd terms
by clicking this Odd Terms box.
This leaves the sine function
that we had in place.
It eliminates all the
odd terms in the series.
It eliminates all the even
coefficients and leaves us only
with the odd ones.
But there are more
of them, so we
should be able to do a
better job of approximating
the square wave.
So let's continue.
Let's try changing b_3 to
get a good approximation.
Well, I could push
b_3 to the left,
and I get a sharper
spike in the middle.
That doesn't look too good.
It looks better to
push b_3 to the right
and flatten out the top.
But when I do that, the
top becomes too low.
And so maybe I made a
mistake in choosing b_1 so
that the maxima agreed.
Maybe I should have made
b_1 a little bit bigger.
Now you can see the
white curve there--
that's giving me the multiple
of the sine wave itself,
the one that I'm
controlling by this slider.
And I guess I should push it
up so that my flat part comes
closer to the top
of the square wave.
Maybe that's a
better approximation.
Well, I can continue
playing this game,
trying out various multiples
of higher sine functions,
and going back to try to
fix up what I had before.
In fact, what we
should be trying to do
is create a least squares fit.
You should try to look at
the root-mean-square distance
between the Fourier series
and the target function,
and minimize that distance.
That distance can be
read out in this tool
by clicking the Distance
button down here.
And so the
root-mean-square distance
between the green curve
and the yellow one
is 0.24 and so on, in this case.
Let me come down here
and kill the formula.
We know the formula
well now, and it
makes the screen a little less
cluttered if we get rid of it.
And let me reset the values
of the coefficients to zero,
and start to try to
approximate this square wave
again by watching the
root-mean-square distance
between the Fourier
series that I'm creating
and the target function.
So I'll start with b_1 in
this case, If I move it down,
the distance increases.
If I move it up, the distance
decreases more and more slowly.
But now when b_1 becomes
greater than one,
it starts to increase.
So let me push it down again.
I can use these little arrow
keys to step the value of b_1.
That's very convenient.
I'm just watching the
root-mean-square distance,
this number up here.
I'm trying to make that
as small as possible.
It's a measure of
the closeness of fit.
Ah, it just started
to increase again.
Let me step up.
And I found the value of one.
I didn't set it to one.
I set it to the value that
minimized this number.
And that's the right
quantity of the sine wave
to put in, if you want to mix
up the square wave, or rather pi
over 4 times the square wave.
Let's look at b_3.
Again, if I decrease
b3, things get worse.
The root-mean-square
distance increases.
But if I increase b_3
above the value of zero,
that number is getting smaller.
Now it's growing again.
I think I'll stop there
and use these arrow keys.
That's better, that's better,
that's better, that's worse.
Let me go back.
And I find the
value 0.33 for b_3.
That's the optimal
amount of the sine of 3t
to put in if you want
to mix up the formula
for this square wave.
I'll do one more.
Any guesses for what the
optimal value of b_5 should be?
It's not going to be negative.
That will increase the
root-mean-square distance.
Let's push it up in
the positive direction.
That's about right.
That's worse, that's
better, that's
better, better, better, worse.
I come down here.
That's optimal.
We've discovered by
experimentation with this
applet that the optimal
value of b_5 is 0.200.
Each one of these
coefficients seems
to have optimal value equal to
the reciprocal of the index.
1/3 in this case, 1 in this
case, 1/5 in this case.
And I predict that the
optimal value of b_7
is going to be 1/7,
which is about 0.14.
There you go.
it's right in there.
So this applet lets you
understand the true meaning
of the Fourier coefficients.
They're the multiples of the
sine waves or the cosine waves
which give you the optimal fit,
in terms of a finite Fourier
series, to the target function.